russell westbrook's confidence james
harden's flavor
chris paul's hbcu support nba fashion
has taken
center stage but that wasn't always the
case in 2005
former commissioner david stern
implemented a strict dress code
the code required players to wear
business casual attire when they
participated in league activities
any non-active player sitting on the
bench had to wear a sports coat
the code also forbade chains pendants
and medallions this rule was
unprecedented
no major sports leagues in north america
had implemented a dress code but after
malice in the palace took place a year
earlier the league felt the need to
rework the negative image the public may
have had
of the nba tell me what to wear
to go play basketball you know what i
mean
nba players weren't fond of the rule the
former mvp winner and one of the best
players in the league had to offer
was feud as the poster boy and therefore
a target
iverson and many others unapologetically
dressed in baggy throwback jerseys
oversized t-shirts and chains negative
connotations were attached to this
attire
and the black individuals in them to
enforce a rule regarding self-expression
in a league made up predominantly of
black americans
had zero chance of going over well over
time the players evolved with the
protocols in the latest fashion
they started to add designer brands to
their wardrobe
the likes of gucci louis vuitton and
balenciaga
tv networks like tnt added energy to the
wave
by showcasing arena entrances to the
public
the league and the players found common
ground the code was loosened
and the nba grew into what we see today
the most
fashionable league in the country and a
runway experience for nba fans